okay so I have some names here they are
your names and this is this is our class
role in our surname alphabetical order
okay so I've got I've got these days
down here and I've got me you'll see why
in a second yeah actually I think my
name is lost cuz you're right no I know
my 94 I should do before you Lucas I
mean anyway that's okay i'll let you
stay there look let's see what we can do
with this this is going to be a height
calculator okay you're like what yeah
yeah yeah yeah you you are so so please
make a new spreadsheet and start putting
down these names okay now you're like oh
hi it's not very interesting but
actually we can do lots of cool
spreadsheet tricks with it okay so i'll
give you a second to take some names
down give you a second to do that and
because I've got my spreadsheet
formatted a little too like the foot is
big enough so you could read it but that
means I can't fit all the names all the
way down so do you remember we had a
trick for how we could scroll further
down like this right but still have that
top road this top row here still have it
visible no matter how far I squad
remember how I did it how did I do it
yes yeah okay very good so in case you
didn't catch that up the top here in the
Microsoft causes the ribbon so I don't
know why it looks like my favorite to me
but anyway up in the river and you want
to go to the View tab okay and then in
here in the middle we want to freeze
panes okay click on that one and the
more we one is the top row ok so I'll
freeze the top row
like so that's okay that's all right we
can catch up later now that i've frozen
that row i can scroll further down and
you can still see name and height ok sir
i'm gonna do a couple of things we're
missing some people so so that i don't
have gaps in my data i'm going to delete
those rows okay so i'll come back up in
a second so the easiest way to delete a
row is to go over here too so for
example I've got Britney on row 21 here
okay so right click on the 21 on the 21
not on her name but on the number if
you're right click there and you can say
delete so they'll delete the entire row
and everything that is or was in it okay
and everything just floats up and we'll
do the same for everyone else who's not
here everyone okay i'm sorry i'm just
jared wright you can't use cherries no
like actually didn't know his name oh ok
boy is that going to affect my table
well you'll have a different set of data
to the rest of us okay well it'd be nice
to have the same i'll show you how to
put you out in yeah in one second if I
if I right click again and say insert
any anywhere anyway you want really but
Jarrod's just above Andrea so that's
where I put on so I'm right click and
then hit insert Peter can you see what
you need now oh yeah yeah okay can you
raise your hand if you've got all the
data everyone yeah and it's up straight
okay excellent hands down thank you Joe
with your heart oh my love miss cancer
didn't change
okay I'll come to yours ideally good
okay so let's do a few fancy fancy
things ah first a very natural question
is when you've got a whole bunch of
values right but you know almost the
immediate question when you get test
marks back is like what's the average
right what's the average so yeah because
remember my top row is frozen yeah so
okay good so mind goes from 1 to 20 now
depending where are you so I to freeze
you want to go to the View tab and then
freeze panes and you want the top rotor
all right now I want to work out the
average and this is a spreadsheet right
so surely it can work out the average
for us here's the easiest way I'm you
remember you start eating equals an
equation write a formula right if you
wanted to add up with a bunch of things
you'd say take the song right well if
you want to work out the average what do
you think is the name of the thing we
have to put in there you just say well I
want an average there you go ok so if I
open brackets now and I'm going to
select all of the heights all of those
numbers okay so there's a couple
different ways to do this you can use
your mouse and just drag and highlight
all of those cells okay if you're going
to use a keyboard like me you can hit up
once okay that's got my height now if
you hold down the shift button and now
cursor up up up up up up up it will go
all the way up to the top there you go
and I'm going to stop at a be Abby's the
first one in the list there okay and
then if i hit enter BAM very good and
there's an average height so if i press
enter it'll close the bracket for me
so my juices name okay so something have
you are did you go did you include the
top with top cell so sure have babies
much okay hands up if you've got the
average there there's a show yeah cool
all right good hands down yeah let's do
some more before we have any further no
don't highlight like you just want all
of these numbers I just all the numbers
I'll show you what I've got I've got on
b2 colon be 26 yeah so that's what it
should have IM me yeah okay so that
means go from one cell to another ok
good let's be a bit fancy okay
everything's so drab and black and white
right now so I want to do some
formatting here for instance what I
might like to do is color these Heights
based on whether they're smaller or
greater okay so highlight all of the
heights for me okay from my life up to
Abby's higher okay or in reverse if
you're like me to do that ok so I I hope
down shift and I went up and down until
I've got the more selective all right
now after that I'm going to go up to the
Home tab up at the top okay keep all
right everything's still selected and
then right there in the middle well
pretty close to the middle there's an
icon that says conditional formatting
which is exactly what it sounds like
right namely it walk and it will form at
things differently in however I like
based on what kinds of conditions those
values have okay so if you click on this
you get all kinds of different options
look at this so one that i'm going to
start us off with and then you can go
ahead and experiment to me like is I
like color scales ok so I'm going to go
into the middle of the list there and
then you've got all these different
things that you can choose to color by
so for instance
you have a go at this one right so
that's the bottom left color scale it
goes from dark green down to white okay
so if I select that now look at what's
happened okay what's going on now based
on how tour someone is what value is in
there right it's a deeper green for a
higher value or as you go further down
you can see you've got sort of lighter
ones ok so the darker it is the tall of
that person is exactly right or I could
do it in reverse couldn't I okay I'll be
miss up here is the shortest person in
the class good on your severe ah maybe
you want to do it in reverse maybe a
smaller number is what you want to
highlight so if you go back and you
select everything you got a conditional
formatting color scales and you select
the one next to it so you can see it's
going to go from white to green in
reverse and now you can see my shortest
person in the class sepehr he is the
deepest shade of green okay so you can
go and experiment this heaps of little
things there maybe you don't want colors
maybe what you want is if I go to data
bars well if you pick one you'll see
let's pick out red red red road hi there
you go freeze there's red now you have a
look the width of the bar directly
corresponds to how tall somebody so if I
got to Darcy right they go his when is
full because he is the tallest person in
the class right as you have spoke I
don't know I was told at home to my
phone here so they go this is the first
and then again if I come back to the
shores person my class his is the
smallest as a proportion of the full
height ok so hundred don't have to go
all the way there and we're going 24 is
that the refraction you can muck around
with that